Hello 大家好
今天给公务员朋友分享一波电脑和手机端
如何用AI写公文的方法
因为这东西有严格的格式和用于体系
对很多新人来说难如登天
所以大家都会找寻各种素材
或学习或借鉴
不过有了AI之后
比以前方便多了
以前还要用全文搜索工具
查找相关内容
现在完全可以让AI帮你学习和生成了
电脑端还是用Theris Studio
直接去官网下载即可
各系统都有客户端
然后我们到规机流动
注册个账号
点击左下角的APM1
新建复制即可
这里免费用户就给了一些额度
用光后就得消费了
不过已经很便宜了
如果你就想FairB不花
也有方法可以直接去OpenRouter搜索MAIDSRE这是微软提供的魔改版DeepSeq点击右下角API即可免费申请
然后打开Chairage Studio的设置
选择规机流动
API密钥这里就粘贴你刚刚复制的那个
API地址保持默认
然后点击底部的管理
添加上任意你喜欢的模型即可
最后我们还要在嵌入列表里
随便选一个方便后续知识库的使用
建议选择BGE-M3
如果你是在OpenRouter里申请的API
就点击OpenRouter
直接粘贴密钥即可
API地址保持默认
还是点击管理
搜索Microsoft-Mai-DS-RE
添加即可
当然这里也有一些其他的国外模型
你也可以挑选一些免费的添加
嵌入模型这里呢没有用规机流动里的BJ1-M3即可然后点击左侧的知识库添加随便填个名称在嵌入模型这里选择BJ1-M3即可
之后在目录这里
选择一个装好了公文素材的文件夹即可
提示已完成后
即可在对话页面任选模型
让它根据知识库的内容
帮你查找生成公文
顺便说下
AI生成的内容都是Markdown格式
你直接粘贴到Word里
它是不支持此语法的
所以可以在AI工具里复制后
粘贴到这个网站
即可转换为Word文档
你再进行修改即可
手机端也有一个零成本的方法
就是用飞书最新的知识问答功能
既可以帮你基于互联网内容回答
也可以基于本地上传的文档
音频视频进行问答并且免费使用DeepSeq R1模型我们只需要点击底部的上传它就会上传到左上角的
我的空间知识问答里了
不过注意
不要在知识问答这里直接传
不然没用
之后随时在手机端的飞出上
即可让AI基于这个知识库
回答或生成公文内容了
不过现在处于适用阶段
所以功能还不是完整版
反正现在是不限容量
不收费还方便
想体验完整版功能的话
可以去申请内测
它有一个好处就是
你可以建群
邀请别人使用你的知识库了
不过群人数会有限制
既可以基于知识库生成内容
也可以当做一个云端素材站
随时全文搜索
超级方便
好了
就给大家介绍到这里吧
可在私信中发送关键字工具
按发布日期获取本期分享
如果视频对你有帮助
记得转发支持
我们下期再见